Tom Brady was talking about pro football
and this is on his weekly appearance on
the Boston radio station WEEI and here's
Tom I think now I think in some ways pro
football is more glorified college
football maybe at the transition it's a
more similar game than what it used to
be you know when I first started so it's
much football now is removing some of
the physical element of the game it's
just it's more of a space game and you
know you see a lot of kind of college
plays you know more in the pro game now
than than what I remember when I started
so you know that's just kind of how
things that went over the last 20 years
yeah I don't know how many years Tom's
talking about but it feels like this
spread offense that we saw and we see in
college football it's like big 12
football in my opinion it's hard to play
defense it's all the rules benefit the
offense and we're seeing this explosion
of offensive numbers and Brady's been a
part of this with that spread offense
they're springing Peter King NBC sports
football morning in America must read
every Monday Pete joins us now what do
you make of Tom Brady's comments therapy
well Dan I think it's been I think this
has been a you're right this year has
really been the sort of pivot point for
what's happening in football and it's
why I think the NFL really has to be
careful because in my opinion I think I
think when you when you make rules
Terry McCauley told me this now the new
NBC rules analyst and I think he's hit
the nail on the head when you make a
rule you've got to make sure that it
doesn't you know it doesn't put the
balance way over the top to either
offense or defense and I think in what
they're doing right now I mean I was I'm
in San Francisco right now is with Joe
Staley yesterday the 49ers and he you
know usually it's if you're ox is not
getting gored they're happy but Joe
Staley you know the 12 year offensive
tackle for the Niners basically said I
don't like the way the game is going so
you even
respect that offensive guys saying look
the NFL is going too far I think the NFL
really is trying its best to make sure
that you don't have anymore Brett
Hundley playing nine games situation and
hey you know any year but you know
that's that's the sport that's the sport
if you take too much of the teeth out of
the sport it's going to be you're going
to be the Western Athletic Conference
and I just think the NFL is got to
really rethink how far it's gone so far
this year yeah and when we had terry
macalmon last week he said look the
priority the main priority of these
officials is to protect the quarterback
but I I do think at some point you have
to we're never gonna level the playing
field because offensive numbers are up
ratings are up you know the NFL
understands this nobody's tuning in to
watch defense but I think if you want to
be fair to your sport then you have to
at least have something that says to the
defense hey we're gonna we're gonna help
you out a little bit here I don't know
what that is Pete but it just feels like
every time there's a new rule it goes
against the defense agree totally and I
think the whole thing right now is I
think the NFL must must must protect the
quarterbacks both for their long-term
health and for the image of this game
but I've got to tell you some of the
some of the roughing calls you know the
four fingers on Tom Brady's helmet
against Indianapolis was absolutely
absurd the Clay Matthews and Kendricks
calls in week 2 I mean you see them
every week and and look here's the
bottom line and I'm just telling you the
NFL always uses this one word with its
officials consistency we want
consistency I want you to tell me if
you're a referee and you're monitoring
the pocket what in the world are you
supposed to do I can tell you these
officials who've gotten out of the game
I just I'm telling you they're thrilled
to not have to adjudicate the impossible
talking to Peter King NBC sports
football morning in America Giants and
Eagles coming up tonight I don't know if
there's a point where
can a like play himself out of this role
this year then you know the funny thing
about this Eli thing is that everybody
is talking about Eli as though this is
sort of a new thing I mean Dan this has
been happening for years it's been you
know Eli is quite possibly and there's
been a lot of great ones over the years
the the best most gentlemanly high
achieving player since I've been around
New York sports you know and I've lived
in the area since 1985 he's an amazing
human being does a lot for this
community and all that but has anybody
been watching football the last five or
six years I mean by most metrics he's in
the lower quadrant and maybe even lower
than that and almost everything and and
I I don't know what people thought was
going to happen this year
Eli needs to have tremendous protection
mmm that's all there is to it he needs
to have great protection and this
offensive line even though it's got some
new pieces is not protecting a line nor
creating an Elfa lanes for steak on
Berkeley and so when that happens the
offense is going to be a fizzle and
that's pretty much what you've seen but
based on that was se Kwang's still the
right pick if you know I don't think so
and I never did think so I mean I I've
always thought in look I totally respect
Dave gentlemen because I think he
believes and this was told to me that
there was not one of these quarterbacks
even after Mayfield
who we loved enough to take anywhere
very high so if that's what he chose the
Giants basically now have to think that
in a top-five next year which is
probably where they'll be drafting in
the top five next year they're gonna
have to get they're gonna have to get a
quarterback maybe the Oregon kid or you
know look I don't know I don't watch
much of college football so they're
gonna have to get one of those guys they
probably should have gotten them this
year but look Dave gentlemen has proven
in his last two drafts
he's taking Christian McCaffrey number
eight he's taken say coin Berkeley
number two he goes against the grain and
he's a little bit of a of a personnel
dinosaur in that regard you where did
you make of Odell Beckham and his
sit-down with ESPN I I don't I don't
know I think it was almost like little
Lil Wayne was who was his blanket you
know was his security whatever I don't
really understand why that was a
together interview but I don't know I
guess they're friends I you know look
you know Dell Beckham took the money and
he's got to accept the fact that I mean
why do you sign the contract if you've
been begging for the contract and you
sign the contract and you have four or
five bad weeks I guess for at the time
he did that interview and all of a
sudden it's time to jump ship dude
you're not going anywhere
you better make the best of this
the Cowboys situation that it feels like
there's you know an undercurrent there
with dak Prescott as you know the future
of this franchise is their quarterback
you've got you know Jerry and Dez and
Allen Hurns questioning back Prescott
and so what do you make of the Cowboys
so far this season I mean I made it
dak Prescott simply has to be better
that Ray Eggman had some telling
comments on the radio in Dallas this
week on the ticket that where he said
essentially you know quarterback has to
anticipate stuff that happens in the
secondary and he simply has to be more
accurate there he has to be an accurate
passer and I think those are the two
things right now that you see that are
that are troubling dak Prescott and I
understand they don't have the franchise
receiver you know a lot of teams don't
have a franchise receiver and they
figure out a way to get it done I think
the other issue here is jerry jones
jason garrett the funniest quote of the
week was jerry jones saying I'm not
second-guessing who we should have gone
for more than one how hilarious is that
but but you know look Pro Football Focus
does numbers for my column every week
and I asked them this week what was what
were the chances of the Cowboys making
that making that fourth down that when
when Garrett punted and they came back
it's I forget it was either 73 or 75
percent and so you know you got a there
are times in the NFL where you got to
take chances I didn't even think that
was a particular trance the chance to be
taken was punting the ball and hoping to
get it back and be able to score and win
the game and obviously they didn't do
that so I think in general then I think
we've seen a shift starting last year
with Doug Peterson coaches are basically
throwing away the old book you know they
thrown away the right wing book and I
think they're doing stuff that is not
only a little bit out there in
traditional football but is a smarter
play that you know Frank Reich 63%
chance that that they were gonna make
that play on fourth and four you know
against Houston when everybody's killing
Frank Reich well that's better than 50%
now you can question which what what
categories Pro Football Focus is using
but I've seen it I've seen how they do
that it all seems logical to me and the
fact is there are times when you have to
say to your team look it's a smarter
idea even though this seems very against
the grain and just look and see what
Doug Peterson did all last year he he
set the stage for what's happening right
now and I think I think coaches need to
go to school on this and go to school on
it pretty quick how desperately do you
think the Eagles are trying to secure a
running back if it's LeSean McCoy or
Le'Veon Bell I think they have to they
have to get one and I think I don't
think they want to saddle themselves
with another salary
you know like lay beyond building they
don't have the wiggle room right now
long term could be paying Le'Veon Bell
like
be - they just they don't they don't
have that that kind of money right now
long-term to spend McCoy makes more
sense to me I think it's interesting
over the next two weeks I think if the
bill to lose a couple of games you know
that Brandon being is hugely a fan of
remaking his team he's he's had no
hesitancy in trading with anybody for
anything at any time
howie Roseman is pretty much the same
thing so it wouldn't surprise me I'm not
anticipating it but it wouldn't surprise
me but they definitely have to go out
and get some help in their backfield
what would be your biggest concern with
the Rams right now or maybe long-term
this season injuries in the secondary
you know Marcus Peters wasn't himself
last week and you know since he's been
hurt
there obviously without Khalid maybe for
the season but at least for you know
eight or ten weeks that's the biggest
concern I would have like what happens
if I mean and in them I'm just I'm
throwing this out there because you know
obviously were we're only about four
months ahead of ourselves what happens
if they play in the Super Bowl against
Kansas City with the existing rosters
that each team has with the trouble that
the Rams are having in the secondary now
they don't have a great outside rush at
all they barely have a good outside rush
and so if Patrick mahomes essentially
has that secondary to throw against and
the ability to run around and escape you
know the interior rush that the Rams
have I probably would like the Chiefs in
that game but again if the long season
you never know but the secondary of the
Rams I think would be concerning be good
to visit with you safe travels thanks
for joining us as always and you're
welcome Dan have a great day that's
Peter King NBC sports football morning
in America column for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you
[Music]